good morning gamers it's minecraft day
the favorite kind of day i love
minecraft
no i'm not addicted okay sven oh god no
sven is lost again sorry guys another
rescue mission necessary
get away from him sven get away from
that sturdy sheep come here
teleport teleports man get away from him
oh god oh god thank god
stay there stay stay there sit never
speak to
him again you come near my dog again if
you so even go
close to breathing in this distance
that's right don't look at me when i
speak
look at me when i speak to you i mean
where's my where's my axe
i will put no you know what even better
i will put this
and i think you know where i will put it
mr sheep mr
water sheep you stay in this prison and
you stay in this person forever
jeb what kind of name is he
all right let's name him actually jeb
this time
because i want to see what this is all
about
that's what this is all about no way i
pick up the wrong thing oh yeah i have
this ocean explorer map
uh but first how do you do it okay you
put this here and then you type
jab underscore and it says yeah
underscore
okay all right all right who's shooting
me
who shoot at me ah
yo you are not water cow what did water
cow go
ah water cow oh
god water cow where are you which one is
water cow
which one is water cat
[Applause]
[Music]
god i keep getting sidetracked also i
improved
the ikea tower it looks really nice
i like it it's really nice from a
distance too uh what else i
changed flooring does anyone care of
course you do what
pewdiepie changed flooring in minecraft
that's awesome listen here you little
scoundrel i don't like you i'm giving
this
oh my god that's awesome yay
he's changing color
[Music]
why okay all right you know what i'm not
gonna lie
that was pretty epic i'm not gonna you
know i'll give credit where credit is
due
so i'm gonna feed you for the first time
in days but only to keep you alive
all right don't get any hopes you're
staying there forever
oh gosh wait sorry i gotta i gotta i
gotta do this well
just get just give me one just give me
one second i'll just get it
okay let's feed the these bastards no
not you
which one is water cow which one of you
is water cow
[Music]
one cow lucky cow is going to become
watercolor oh okay you can become
watercolor follow me
follow gosh watercolor would not give me
this trouble
come here hey hey you have one destiny
in this life
and it's to become what a cow with
enough training
get in just get it just get it there you
go or you worry cap
i'm gonna train you every day and one
day you're gonna live up to become
workout gosh darn it
okay where was i yes yes yes of course
of course
my horse jurgen okay i'm not gonna lie
that's pretty epic
[Music]
oh god there's so many distractions in
this game i never know what i'm doing
seriously oh yes i have one quick thing
i really
do so if you take gun powder and paper
which i've been farming from the paper
farm that i have out there you see the
paper farm
uh you can make okay so i'm a minecraft
veteran so i remember
fireworks not neither freaky dicky how
since when did they add fireworks all
right yep
if that is your real name look at he
doesn't yeah you better not look
whoa
where's the explosion is that it
wow that's so cool
hey jorgen look at this
he loves it he loves it where's sven
sven look at this man come here
come here boy all right look at this
he loves it all right sven it's time for
this epic gamer
to hand out on epic adventure through
the nether
portal how do i oh yeah
later later gamer so last episode
or a few episodes ago i tried to blow up
this guy's house right
it didn't really work out but i have
another plan
also apparently you can find a bunch of
stuff in the nether like materials and
like
these blaze rods that are really
important i haven't seen
anything where are they help me
help me garsh dornie where like where
hello looking all i see is pigs
in the stupid nether i hate pigs they're
not good
not good like melon food why is anyone
what
okay gamers here we freaking go wait is
this the wrong portal
all right it's the wrong port i went the
wrong way
ah another portal more like
nothing in here portal hopefully
okay gamers three hours later
literally we are here okay
this is it
oh it's getting dark that's perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay gamers this is going to be an epic
gamer moment because we're going to burn
down their house it's all made of wood
right i wish i could bring jargon to
this because he would love to see this
jurgen loves to see other people's
houses burn down it's one of his
favorite things
okay all right gamers sweden
okay okay don't worry don't worry don't
worry gamers
oh god i made the business ah they shoot
themselves dummy dumb
okay so how do i not die death how do i
knock that
do i start from the top yeah yeah yeah
yeah we start from the top fire burns
from top to bottom
everyone knows this what am i doing
gosh it's so dark i'm like legally blind
i'm gonna lit up
don't worry guys i'm gonna leave okay
okay this is part of the
freaking place
oh no oh god
oh no not your pretty place it looks so
good
i am burning i am burning i am on fire i
am on fire with this house
it hurts oh god does it hurt
oh god all right i better bounce uh oh
god
all right gamers it's gaming week
gaming minecraft months
oh what are you gonna do hello what are
you gonna do
this is for you again oh god they're
killing me
all right all right okay
you're shooting each other it's pathetic
pathetic
oh god i'm dying oh god jurgen
you're getting back up oh god i'm almost
dead
it's fine it's fine gamers it's gaming
week
okay gamers time to bounce oh that's
what i like to see
epic smash
like if that was epic all right i think
this one takes us back home actually
it was epic not you it was very epic
here you go
eat all right gamers
uh sven you're gonna please
look away because i have something
that i have to do and i don't really
i've been dreading to do this i'm gonna
have to uh
go sick
[Applause]
i'm sorry i'm sorry
it has to be done okay suddenly i feel
like sleeping
crazy oh my god what are you doing here
what are you selling garbage you're
selling garbage
slide balls is okay i'll take it i'll
take a slime ball
i'll take a sign ball oh don't don't
mind me
yes i know i'm rich it's whatever uh
just because you're poor like don't feel
bad it's all about the stoics all right
give me the slime ball give me the slime
ball give me the slime ball
i asked you for one thing uh slimeboard
please
can i level up this guy no you can't
what
four for one slime ball get out of the
way i spit on you
oh god he took my money he took my money
took my money four for one slimeball
let's
get the freak out of my house how dare
you stay where you stand
get out of here i will kill you too
technically you're not responsible but i
will do it but i don't want to kill in
front of jurgen you're
you're kind you're cousins whatever you
are okay slime ball
by slime ball stupid slime ball dummy
dum dum you sven
you if you saw what i just saw you would
be so angry so i'm not
even gonna tell you what just happened
so the reason why i murdered all these
sheeps
is because apparently you can dye the
sheep and then that way you don't have
to
be poo pooing if you know what i mean
but there's a bunch of freaking
all right lamps i'm really sorry about
that i hope we can still work together
gosh why are they all still here do i
physically have no one
i need to separate them and i have no
i must have some i have no that i knew
i had one god damn i'm a gamer so this
is how you know i'm a gamer get out of
my sight
how dare you stick with him yeah all
right i'll deal with you in a second
all right i need you all to come over
here y'all come over here
that's right dummy dumps you're a bunch
of dummy dumbs you know that
bing bong bing bong
god i'm locked in now gosh damn it i
need carpets
asa freaking pee pee all right here we
go
put it get out of my way i hate sheep
okay all right sheep come here dummy
dumps you're a bunch of dummy thumbs
you fell for the oldest trick in the
book all this trick in the book and you
fell for it
dummy dumbs sven what are you doing here
don't talk to these guys
don't talk to these guys i don't want
you near them
and we'll do another section here
perfect okay
so if i get this right i can die i can
buy them
oh me freaking licky ricky that's
awesome
so now when they freak uh they'll make
white
uh yellow babies question mark yes
all right you guys be blue okay
all right awesome i like this and then i
want red
oh it looks so crazy i friggin i'll do
more blue i like balloon
alright today gamers eat thanks sheep
dummy dumbs sven i told you not to talk
to these guys please
okay you guys will be black [ __ ]
and oh no i ran out of die
which means you die okay
i treat you well i treat you all well
but you have to behave oh no
ran out oopsie oopsie oopsie
man i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
get it let's get out of here let's get
out of here let's ditch these creeps can
you guys freak off
oh both cow is back gamers
boat cow is back bro cow is back now get
out
get out i don't want to kill a llama oh
that's so weird the llamas just
disappeared
hey are you guys making out jesus sven
sven you're not oh god ah
okay it's fine it's fine what was i
doing oh yes yes yes yes i got it i got
it i got it so now
we can finally we can finally
as we say in this fandom complete the
ikea tower
in its glorious form the way it's meant
to be
all right sheep chop chop chop shop
shop let me show and hey hey hey
hey hey i wanna i want nothing i want
nothing to do with you you're garbage
you're trash you're all trash
you mean nothing to me at least you're
not yet
think about that at least you're not yet
oh my god you guys grow fast you're all
right stop growing
stop i said stop okay so now we complete
ikea tower
how should we do it like white and then
blue or oh my god ikea tower is so
beautiful i'm teary-eyed i never thought
a monument would have such impact and
meaning for me
but it's truly a sight to see if you
guys
ever pass by in my area in my minecraft
server
you gotta come check out the ikea tower
i i'm telling you
[Music]
let's sing
[Music]
oh right i forgot to show you guys i got
a swimming pool it's pretty epic look i
got trampoline as well
okay and the best part
it's pot it's it's lava powered
[Music]
i'm actually 12.
okay i know you're impressed too it's
lava-powered
cutting-edge technology only minecraft
veterans would understand
oh my god it's beautiful glory to the
ikea tower
it will guide me in the darkest hour to
my way back home to jurgen
and spend of course please we talked
about this you cannot talk
no he still loves me guys he still loves
me
he chooses not to look at me for for for
a purpose all right
just sit there please it can only be one
boat cow
and one only where did my boat go all
right well fine just
as long as boat cow stays i don't really
care what he does i spent half the time
in this game just categorizing my items
only gamers will understand i don't know
if this is a good idea
but i have this map that goes to
an ocean explorer and i'm like that's
pretty epic
i kind of want to check it out so we're
just going to do that gamers because
that's what minecraft is all about
okay so let's check out this maps van
this looks like it's pretty freaky dicky
far away
uh we might have to bring we might have
to bring
how do i know how far away that is let's
hold it in one hand
yeah we're a tiny little dot aren't we
so and you're gonna have to hold down
the fort
i'm gonna check out through the portal
first all right so let's look at the map
okay looks like we're getting closer so
we have to head north
west okay gamers let's go then my nether
sucks everyone keeps saying
i find i'm really lucky in this game
like i find a lot of stuff but my nether
soccer
it's it is not good don't like it
there's nothing there's nothing here
help me find stuff gamers come on how
north
are we talking here in gamers oh i have
a gamer question
if i didn't make sven sit down and i go
no he wouldn't teleport
further than the nether no that would be
impossible i have so many questions
looks like we went a little far gamers
and
back it goes all right let's try this
portal i think this is from where i got
the map to begin with
and we gotta go no okay fine this this
will do
it'll do as we say in sweden didn't do
it
will you ever restock gosh freaky all
right so he's the one that sold me the
map um
okay we gotta go north north
to my horse god i wish jurgen smergen
was here
should we go should we just get jurgen i
think it'll be quicker anyway
oh yeah you guys told me i don't know if
this is true but if
underneath a bell you should dig a diggy
ah my paper my paper it's gonna get wet
uh i can't see anything hello
[Music]
are you guys lying to me you're lying to
me again never
see this is what happens when you break
trust oh dude
oh wow that was so cool guys thanks for
the tip really appreciate it
apparently i'm supposed to be able to
fit jurgen in the boat which seems crazy
how how does he fit in boat you're gonna
get in the boat
you're gonna get in the boat whoa so if
i drop the lasso
i still haven't that makes no sense
oh i had two of them
no i'm dummy dumb we gotta head out sven
my man i'm sorry but last time you
nearly drowned
and i'm not putting that through again
let's go you're gone hey look it's your
uh
uncle here again maybe one day i i'll
tame uncle
see this is what i like me and jurgen on
adventures
just like having a bro time isn't that
right killing sheep
wait can the water temple be on land no
masaka implausible
wait what nanny the freaky dicky picky
okay so before we head out i'm gonna
have to dig up some sand
for our sand temple now who would bring
their horse to a water temple you might
ask
a man that loves his horse don't judge
right jurgen
normally i would leave you there but i
don't i just don't trust you
oh god i don't like this it's so far
away you know
is that it
okay jargon we set up base here
oh freak it's so deep oh god
ah come on you're again you can swim
right it's fine right oh yeah i have
knock back on my sword
they fly back so far stay
all right cool so it's dark as well
that's excellent i can already
not see underwater i know you can use
like a potion to make you see underwater
and stuff
but that's for lamer gamers and i'm not
a lamer gamer i'm just a gamer
so i think if you put a door oh god this
is not gonna work
what am i doing uh
okay all right i literally can't even
see it anymore
did i bring my aqua infinite helmet no i
didn't i forgot it oh gosh
all right uh
wait is it over there oh it's north
oh it is there i don't think that's it
what what is this yeah whoa what is
it whoa it's so cool die
it's shouting me oh my god it's shooting
me
what is that oh my god all right let's
go to the top first
[Music]
i got what is these laser looking son of
a guns
don't no don't shoot a gamer
i'll block it was that it
is how you got all right i think this is
the entrance
all right so now we just placed
what the freak is that oh it's a fence
freak i put on the wrong thing
okay so i can breathe in the doors
see this i'm actually so nervous
okay all right let's keep our head cool
let's think about who we love and who
we're doing this for i wish i brought
more doors
i i put down the fence i'm supposed to
put down the gate
let me try this just okay
cool
[Music]
yeah i wish i brought an axe
wait i i physically can't break it down
[Music]
what about the gate can i break down the
game oh wait i have the mining sickness
thing
right is that what it is what are you
gonna do shoot with the laser
i didn't mean that
[Music]
oh they're kind of cute i feel bad this
is making me anxious
oh oh god
the words are awesome i freaked out
jurgen i freaked up
you're again you light up my world oh
wait copyright music let's not [ __ ] with
it
goddess i have to reign and be so epic
all the time
can i just have one normal chill episode
where's my boat there you are
is that a freaking wizard izzard oh yeah
it's gaming time
oh god oh god this event
oh this is really bad oh god i'm crazy
that was a bad idea that was a really
bad idea
that was a really bad idea that was
really bad
oh yeah again oh
god
shoo
[Music]
let's not do that i'll do that ah yes
the tower the tower of ikea guys the way
doors hey sven
doors lots of doors
unless you're a door don't talk to me
anymore
rain again it's the desert come on notch
but
i don't work on game anymore not
this make no sense so i just realized
something the map hasn't been filled in
oh it has a little bit i think the water
temple we found is a different one
because it doesn't match the map right
jurgen perkins mergen
i should have set up a camp there
okay
[Music]
all right we are officially in 42
doors let's do this get away get away
okay
okay all right we've been in here
another door i'll take it
let's place a door in each room all
right it looks like i already did that
i swear i've been in here what there's
nowhere to go
are you kidding me oh up i can go up
here
whoa oh gosh i'm gonna get lost okay
don't worry i'll i'll i'll remember just
follow the doors
aloha this makes absolutely no sense by
the way
i bet everyone else that did this just
like prepared properly i'm just like
doors
i'll bring doors oh you can go down
there
uh-huh all right what about here
there's something here gamers nothing
door door door
all right so that means we got to go
down here
hey hey dude i'm a door
oh all right i'm a door i'm a door
where'd he go oh god oh there he is
oh god frick this place is huge
all right all right let's go back
there's nothing here i'm trying to
remember the layout
so that when it all comes down
i will not freak up oh gosh it's dark in
here all right so nothing up here
are you down here no nothing what am i
doing
nothing here either what the freaky oh
god i'm so anxious
this is so stressful
if i die jurgen knows all right that's a
bit more than i bargained for eat ass
oh wait oh i take damage if i hit that
i'm just a guy with a door i'm just the
guy with the door
god what's freaking me out dude okay we
can go up here again
36 more doors it's fine it's fine plenty
of doors we got plenty of doors
wait where am i oh god door
door oh god i'm stuck
i'm stuck door door i need the door asa
freaking pp
oh if they bubble down they die
epic i think i'm supposed to go up here
freak away you little pee
pee pay okay okay come on
oh i've been here
close the door
so i think the treasure is in that thing
and if i just drink this vote cow milk
the potion disappears
and i can just mine my way through
oh we found it door
door here oh damn it we got the thing
again
blurb
give me that gold
yes oh god i need to
get the goal give me the gold
give me the gold give me the gold
[Music]
oh god thor oh god thor
how greedy are you gonna be felix okay
it's perfect i can literally stand here
okay okay oh we got all the gold we got
all the gold
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
time for this gamer to bounce
from wherever he came from which i don't
really remember yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
oh god let's go let's go
let's go yeah
you're good you're getting after me yeah
i can do something
uh i got the gold jargon i got the gold
cheesed my way through it baby oh my god
that was stressful
let's head back home here again you were
a good boy jurgen
oh god we're sinking here again you're
gonna stop dancing
jurgen this is not a dancing contest you
can't do the stinky leg here can we
talked about this many times
oh god it makes me uncomfortable that
you're walking on two legs can you stop
please
here's what happens when you teach your
pets the stinky leg
oh she's never looked as beautiful
look at that symbol of trust and hope
here again
we're back home sven it was epic
i believe i gotta drink some more of
that uh delicious
[Music]
i don't mind if i do thank you
don't judge me now what am i gonna do
with that gold you might ask sven
well it's for an old friend
all right guys that's it for this week's
episode wait what
[Music]
smash like for another one
and i see you and sven tomorrow
bye
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price